he brought up the Elon Musk Twitter
thing I mean this is something you've
we've been talking about for weeks now
I'm sure you've now that it's been 24
hours since it's happened how are you
processing this since yesterday they
realized the poison pill was gonna
backfire and they were going to be in
court for the rest of their lives and
finally they caved and they said Elan
you know [ __ ] we can't do nothing about
it I guarantee you this took place I'm
telling you right now now I may be wrong
lawyers they had a meeting with the
legal team and they said okay what do
what can we do at this point if we pull
the poison pill
you can pull the poison pill just make
sure when the market finds that you
didn't let Elon Musk buy Twitter and he
sells off his 9.2 percent the same
amount of shares he owns as Morgan
Stanley just make sure you can make the
stock go up the next three quarters
because if it goes below 30 after you
push Elon away and he sells off the
other 9.2 if it goes below 30 we're
going to be in court for five ten years
if you guys are okay with that then use
the poison pill if not let the man buy
the company and then finally everybody
looked around and there were certain
people that probably still didn't want
to do it and they wanted to still use
the poison pill but some of the guys
that are just on the board to help the
company make more money said sell the
company I'm telling you I think the
decision was made that logically and
then they sold off to Elon they couldn't
do anything Elon one thing you got to
say about this guy man listen you know
name the greatest trolls of all time
Trump's on that list
right name the greatest trolls of all
time
are these they call Jake Paul's coming
up but he's a young troll yeah I'm
talking like legendary trolls of all
time you got to put him up there
you got to put uh uh you know uh uh who
else would you put in the wrestling
world and UFC you got to put Conor in
that world as a great truck
I'm talking getting under the skin type
of a yeah so text exchange came up right
you want to show the text exchange
between Muslim Gates I don't know if you
saw this or not uh so here's a text
exchange that came out make it a little
smaller so we can see it uh so the first
text goes out can you do it or no
exactly the top part of it apparently so
apparently Bill Gates sets up Elon Musk
to discuss philanthropy on climate
change but Elon asked if he still had a
half a billion Auto short on Tesla Bill
said yes he hasn't closed it out so Elon
told him to get lost no idea if this is
true LOL well Elon responds here's what
he said on the bottom right there he
says do you still have a half million
Sometimes some people say he says sorry
but I cannot take your philanthropy on
climate change seriously when you have a
massive short position against Tesla the
company doing the most to solve climate
change and so people ask Elon Musk and
look what he said go out there and click
on his Twitter account to see if this is
[ __ ] and if this is real right no
you should first go to his account I
know you can go to that trolling he
responds go a little lower you'll see
one of the ones when he responds and he
says that is the text exchange I don't
know who got it go a little lower go a
little lower yeah you respond somewhere
there that he did respond okay anyways
go back to the uh uh post that he put up
there Bill Gates and then he posted this
in case you need to lose a boner fast
that's Bill Gates and that image of
Apple so you're basically saying that
Elon Musk is one of the greatest trolls
of all time it's what I'm saying to you
is what I'm saying to you is this guy
cornered Twitter's board to say I dare
you to not let me buy the company I dare
you I think that's how it happened what
was the poll you did yesterday about
Elon Musk I asked the question I said
what percentage of you uh uh how will
you react with Elon Musk uh what do you
call it uh buying Twitter number one are
you leaving and I said number two uh
will you be more active number three you
know you know David [ __ ] you know
something like that and I'll be more
active nothing will change and then who
cares you know how many people said well
leaving two percent everybody was like
yeah I'm gonna be more active the one
that won the most was I'll be more
active don't forget what Elon did Elon
came out and he said do you guys know
the top 10 most followed people on
Twitter
they rarely ever tweet he says do you
know that Justin Bieber hasn't tweeted
but so many times do you know that such
and such person do you know that Barack
Obama only twists this many times why do
we have the top biggest accounts that
are not active on Twitter he's asking
the right question the whole blue you
know that everybody wants that blue
check mark of course he says why don't
we just give the blue check mark to
everybody that pays 299 a month why
don't we do that if you pay 299 a month
let's get rid of all the Bots if you pay
2.99 a month you're not fake because all
these people are creating these fake
accounts right let's eliminate all these
fake accounts that are out there because
they're not paying 2.99 a month I mean I
love what this guy is doing so anybody
and everybody can get the blue chip if
you pay 299 a month whatever the fee is
going to be now he's allowing you know
the new CEO made a few changes that they
allow you to put 10 minute videos we
couldn't do that before was 220 now you
can't put a 10 minute video anyways the
Market's very very happy however
yesterday the legendary Brian stelter
which I don't know if you follow him
he's a famous wrestler
[Laughter]
he goes by the thumb
he's a famous I can't we can't play that
but he said something he says well I
just want you to think about this
imagine you have two parties to go to
one party you can say whatever you want
to say and you're free and another party
you go to people have to be a little bit
more responsible with what they say
which party would you want to go to and
then somebody comments on my tweet and
he says I can't imagine him having ever
been to a single party in his life
before because the biggest thing is
people don't believe the guy's 34 years
old that guy to the left is 34 years old
he's 34 years old Brian do yourself a
favor is contact Diamond Dallas Page on
how to look younger
he needs DVP why more than anybody back
to Elon yeah we're on this topic right
now did you see the latest with Jack
Dorsey now you see what Jack Dorsey had
to say about Elon I sent that to you on
slack what do you think Jack dorsey's
response about Elon buying Twitter first
of all what do you think let me ask you
a question let me ask you a question how
many conversations do you think Elon and
Jack have had in the process of him
buying Twitter what are you non-stop are
you kidding me like you know how he said
he said it's a it's a family Brotherhood
right dude these guys are PayPal Mafia
Brotherhood they're texting calling
they've lived by a certain code that
nobody else knows about Jack's known it
for a longest time elon's already told
Jack I want you to be on the board you
know all this conversation they've
already had the conversations and on top
of that what did come out yesterday
which was interesting because I said the
five things that was gonna happen once
Elon bought it I said number one he's
gonna buy Twitter take it private number
three he's gonna do whatever he's doing
with uh Brady's picture to be eliminated
then it's gonna be Trump's going to be
back and then nation's gonna lose her
mind and all this stuff but the one
thing that the story is not coming out
this even if Twitter lets Trump back on
he may not want to come back on because
he's still pushing truth oh get out of
here with this true social was yesterday
true socially has officially put the
nail in the coffin you don't think he's
just gonna come back to Twitter now
that's not true social is doing that
right there Trump will not return to
Twitter even as Elon Musk purchase his
platform will begin his own truth social
yeah well by the way I don't think
that's a smart move I don't think that's
a smart move
go back to Jack dorsey's quote uh about
Elon as I say even Melania doesn't use
truth like the only person that uses
truth is Trump and nobody can get on it
right
Elon is the singular solution I trust
that's some pretty High Praise but it's
not it's not this is the he said this to
Elon before he said it to
him he said this to you before he said
it's
it's work yeah that's what we call our
business it's it's all set up you know
and for this cat with all the bazillions
of dollars he has
he's got to know he kind of he has a
plan and the plan is like you said was
already discussed before it ever went
out there and he already knew who the
votes were coming in that he needs and
who else needed yo who's going to
partner with them you know to me I don't
I don't believe anything anymore you
know it's like just do your thing Elon
go for it you know if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]